matter of fact in um you know ancient
china's uh
like where like you know their
equivalent of like washington dc like
the white house was called the forbidden
city
and you were not allowed into the
forbidden city as a man
unless you were a eunuch that's right
that's just what it was so many
eunuchs actually rose to have
extreme power yeah in uh in a lot of
those dynasties what a lot of chinese
families would do back in the day
is because the only way to get into the
forbidden city and really get like an
audience with the emperor at that time
if they needed something if they had
like a beef
they would take one of their sons and
castrate them and cut their own balls
off
with a hope that they would one day be
allowed into the forbidden city
and get an audience with the emperor and
then be able to tell the emperor
to do you know to to to help the family
of the castrated boy out
and get revenge on whoever wronged them
and get revenge now their eunuch son has
power and has the emperor's ear
and he tells the emperor hey we gotta
[ __ ] take out this landlord
and really it's just the father who
castrated his son
sent that son into the [ __ ] to the
emperor's house with the hopes that one
day
that kid would have enough power with
his position so close to the emperor to
get
[ __ ] revenge on whoever wronged that
family exactly there is actually a
famous eunuch
who we will get to who did that uh but
it ended up he never really
he it didn't work out he didn't actually
ever get revenge because
as soon as he got made it to the uh to
get to the emperor that [ __ ] emperor
passed away and so on and so forth yeah
well that well that well you just
you didn't have to get to it you just
told this i just told the story i mean
so it's totally the story
and i mean you know what the chinese
names are really [ __ ] hard to
remember i'll be honest with you i think
they should do in history they should do
like they do here well i will tell you
that english names
my name is steve lee well i will tell
you his name was
that's our talk what do you remember
w-e-i-z-h-o-n-g
is x-i-a-n give you want to give that a
whirl the real pronunciation
is there is there if you type that into
google translate will they tell us the
actual
pronunciation if i spell it out so let
me you give it a shot
you give it a shot then i'll give it a
shot and we'll see what the actual one
is
okay so his name zach his first name is
w-e-i
last name z-h-o-n-g
why y'all no z i think i just nailed it
h z h o z h o
n g x i a n
yeah there we go let's see
what how you s zhong jang i'm gonna say
where's
where's john jane where's des because
i'm going to say
let's see speaks chinese right
yeah speaker chine let's see
pronunciation pronounced kiwi no what
yeah catalan pronunciation is fine
with neither one of us foreign
there's no m there try to try the
chinese hong kong pronunciation all
right try the chinese china
pronunciation
none of them work except for the catalan
yeah i guess
what's the danish pronunciation wow
wow
because we may be the first people of
all eight billion people on our planet
to ever [ __ ] try to
get the danish pronunciation of how
about the taiwan how about the
taiwanese pronunciation can't get it
you know what's wild this one shane
do they are they aware of how
complicated and hard it is to remember
those names
a steve or a joe is a lot easier than
wei zhong jin
yeah well i mean they they change their
names a lot you know look at the english
pronunciation
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's sad sharing
so i do you you kind of nailed that one
way
we may need to keep that and put that on
just out of nowhere as one of one more
of our
our plugs yeah
that should be in like the opening like
montage
um yeah so unfortunately for that kid
you know he cut his be cut his piece off
well his father cut his because his
father cut his piece off because
his father had beef with his neighbors
and then unfortunately the emperor after
three weeks into his surge after he woke
up
uh the emperor died so yeah the new
emperor didn't care so the cat made it
all the way to the emperor's side
uh to be his advisor then the emperor
[ __ ] died so that kid
uh he never got revenge for his family
what are you gonna do you know that's a
chance sometimes you swing and you miss
cause you win some you lose some
but that's hilarious that that's
hilarious that that's how brutal
history was that a father was like you
know what to get revenge
on this beef i have i am going to cut my
son's balls off
in the hopes that maybe he will be
picked to be an advisor
to the most powerful man in this region
yeah what a wild thing that's not really
a good dad
like that kid's going to have a lot of
issues that therapy
will not be able to solve yeah like
mike's going to walk and be like i have
some issues
with my dad he cut my nuts out yeah well
here's the thing
my dad i told i've told you guys on
podcast before was a compulsive gambler
and still is a compulsive gambler
and did unfortunately bet 800 which was
pretty close to my mom's life savings at
the time
on my gender he bet 800 and paid up to
his friends that i was gonna have a
vagina
and i did in fact come out with the dick
and balls but at least my dad did not
turn around and cut my balls off
immediately to win the bet
hold on
go make sure you rate review us
subscribe
uh turn on your notifications get jiggy
with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild